it's it was sad walking in here today
it's gonna be sad walking out of here
for the last time and it's a lot to wrap
your arms around but
we love our our fans we love the city of
oakland we thank them and we'll
certainly miss them
john bruden look at that face at the end
too the gruden face yeah we're sad that
we're we won't see you again as we take
750 million in public money from las
vegas because you wouldn't give us any
money for a stadium so
yeah we're leaving i mean i've been
uncomfortable with this from the get-go
this three-year divorce between the
raiders and oakland right the money
grabbed by the raiders they don't want
to pay for their own stadium they want
somebody else to pay for the stadium so
they get what they want in las vegas
don't act on melancholy about oakland
you're choosing to leave and i guess
it's fitting that they fell flat on
their faces on the way out the door
although i feel bad for the raiders fans
yeah i do they should have gotten to
enjoy one last party and and i i said
last week we had the pressure draft the
pressure was on john gruden i thought
they should have that game put away
midway through the third quarter so they
could so everybody could just enjoy it
for the last quarter and a half and
instead they had to worry and they had
to worry they're worrying they blew the
damn game yeah derek carr got booed off
the field yeah well it was a tale of two
halves i mean the raiders dominated the
first half and you thought oh gosh if
they can just come out in the second
half and get one more score on the board
they'll put it away they never did that
the jags dominated the whole second half
and of course made the big clutch drive
at the end of the game to win it but
yeah 91 total yards of offense for the
raiders in the second half that's really
all that needs to be said and
minchumania came through who's the week
one quarterback for the las vegas
raiders oh gosh derek carr of the field
i don't know i and right now i would go
with the field i would
just like that yeah just by a nose
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports